well now that the wedding's behind them
Derek and concentrate on rehearsals
hairspray I need to take a deep breath I
don't if you're Vince just nice way I'm
counting down you know I'm gonna venture
to say that there has never been another
live television production with this
much musical talent we've cried ten
hundred times today the two of us are a
basket cases we have been crying it's
such an emotional journey for everybody
Ariana told me Kristen is like a mom to
all the cast members and miss grande has
become close with the show's Tracy
Turnblad Mady Valley OH
she had a party at her mom's house last
night and I came over and we just I just
had a lot of cast bonding and she's just
the sweetest person how would you like
to come on down to audition oh my god
it's a dream of a lifetime excited man
and now we're finally on sets costumes
are incredible the hair the wigs
it's amazing the cast is incredible -
I'm gonna love them the NBC production
is taking live musicals to a whole new
level with 18 different sets shooting
almost half of the show outdoors plus
don't miss diva duet between Ariana and
Jennifer Hudson I'm excited to sing with
her I'm a fan so how do all these big
voices meet in the middle in this
production I'm J Jennifer Hudson ariana
grande Kristin yeah I mean all you all
are Power singers I think we just
thinking about doing the part right and
it's not about you know we're all used
to doing our separate kind of things but
now we're coming together and play
this show
[Music]